-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys,
due to Hurricane Ian,
the January 6th Committee
just postponed
its public hearing that was
scheduled for tomorrow.
Yeah, all day, Trump was praying
for a rain delay
like a pitcher facing
Aaron Judge.
Like, "Please."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the hearing is postponed.
This morning Trump woke up
like Kevin in "Home Alone."
He's like,
"I made my hearing disappear."
[ Laughter ]
Some political news --
Senator Bernie Sanders said
that he hasn't yet decided
whether he will run
for president again in 2024.
People were like,
"President of what?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Bernie
still hasn't decided.
Meanwhile everyone else is like,
"How many times
do we have to decide this?
No."
[ Laughter ]
Right now, Biden is thinking,
"Please run so I look like
the hot, young stud. Please."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, well,
ahead of midterm elections,
House GOP Leader Kevin McCarthy
and other House Republicans
put out a new ad
promoting their agenda.
But there was one problem --
some of the footage in the ad
that was supposed to be America
was actually footage
from Russia.
[ Laughter ]
That's real.
And that wasn't
the only mistake.
Take a look at this spot.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's so many --
-Wow!
Not even close.
-Riddled.
Riddled with errors.
-Speaking of Russia,
I just heard they announced
they're boycotting
next year's Oscars.
Mm, that's a tough break
for Russia's biggest movie
this year, "I Actually Have
A Lot to Worry About Darling."
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this last night?
NASA intentionally crashed
a spacecraft into an asteroid
to see if it could stop one
coming towards Earth
in the future.
Go, NASA.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the Space Force
was like, "Cool, cool.
So what exactly
is our role again?
Like, what -- what do we do?"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, listen to this --
I heard that the CIA
just launched its own podcast.
The CIA was like, "After
75 years of listening to you,
now you can listen to us."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
everyone loves TikTok,
but sometimes you just
want to skip through
the boring parts of a video
and get right to the good part.
Well, it turns out you can
with this new thing
that we're doing on our show.
For instance,
if you're watching a video here,
you can skip this part...
♪♪
-...and go right to this part.
[ Laughter ]
-Let me give you
another example.
You can skip this part...
and go right to this part.
[ Thuds ]
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The fish tank!
The final example --
you can skip this part...
-I'm doing a part two
to the treadmill video
I did just recently.
-Yeah, and just go
right to this part.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go. Perfect.
Just so you know
that's available.
Switching gears --
ahead of the holiday season,
Macy's announced plans to hire
more than 40,000 new workers.
So divide that between
the remaining Macy's locations,
and you have 40,000 per store.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
In an effort to fight theft,
retailers like Home Depot
are now locking up items.
That's right,
trust Home Depot on security
when they can't even
keep birds out.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news -- the other night,
there was a new --
There's always birds
in Home Depot flying around.
-Come on, there are.
"What's this bird doing in here?
Come on.
It's not a bird store."
-Some TV news -- the other night
there was an all-new episode
of "Celebrity Wheel of Fortune,"
and one of the contestants --
Snoop Dogg --
had a little trouble
with some of the puzzles.
This is real.
Check this out.
[ Bell dings ]
-Snoop?
-"Swallowing the -- the knot"?
[ Laughter ]
-That --
no, that's not right.
[ Bell dings ]
Snoop?
-"Airport teacher."
-No.
[ Bell dings ]
And snoop?
"Toilet Atlas."
[ Laughter ]
-I have no idea.
[ Bell dings ]
-And it's Snoop.
-"Baking onions."
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
[ Applause ]
-Something was baked that night.
It wasn't onions on that one.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, guys, it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet"!
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
I see people scrambling
for them, sharing them.
Everyone has their own,
so it's all gonna be fine.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Higgins, you have your clicker?
-Got it.
-All right.
Your thumb's already on no.
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
Wanna be positive.
-Why --
-I wanna be positive.
-Yeah, but why --
-I'm gonna put "no"
on every one.
-What? You're gonna say no
to all of them?
-Yep, just so it'll be fair.
'Cause Tariq's --
Tariq's gonna go yes --
-Tariq, what are you thinking?
-I voted -- I'm done.
I voted "yes" to everything.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Quest,
I know you're very positive.
You always vote yes.
-Always yes.
-Yes.
-I love my job.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show,
so that you can all like it
and "wetweet" it.
-Nice.
-It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Some people laughing, some
people just stone-- stone-faced.
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
-Some people don't know they
should -- they shouldn't do --
-Yeah, I don't think
it's gonna work.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, oh.
-All right, not bad.
Not bad. 100...
Very honest audience.
I like that, yeah.
-Lot of abstentions.
-Wasn't the -- yeah.
Wasn't the best,
wasn't the worst.
-Yeah. Wasn't worst.
Was fine.
-Let's see this next one here.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Come on. That's true.
-That's rare.
-That's fair.
-That's a rare sighting.
-That's a rare baby name
nowadays.
-Yeah, it's like "What --
What's the name of your baby?"
"It's Cheryl."
-"Cheryl."
-Yeah.
-Gladys.
-All right, here we go.
You cast your votes.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-Oh, barely better.
♪♪
-"Cheryl" --
-I love that -- barely better.
We might not even
tweet one out tonight.
Who knows?
[ Laughter ]
Next one here says...
Oh, that's interesting.
[ Audience groans ]
That one got -- you can't --
you can't boo the jokes.
Just...
[ Laughter ]
...thumbs up or thumbs down.
Please no booing.
-'90s George Carlin.
-I don't need any
audible booing of jokes, yeah.
I don't even think
we need to wait.
Let's just see the results.
This is gonna be a landslide.
Yeah, okay.
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Wow.
-Here we go.
This next one says...
-I'm gonna say
this one's gonna win.
-"It's not connecting,
it needs ink.
Uh, honey, do we need to make
any more CD-ROM labels?"
All right, here we go.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
Squeaky, but very nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You're being very nice tonight.
-Wow.
-You're being a very giving
audience tonight.
I appreciate that.
We're down to our last one.
Here we go.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Cast your vote.
This one...
I feel good -- I feel best
with this one.
I think.
I don't know.
All right.
I think everyone
cast their votes.
We know if it's
gonna win or not.
Let's see the results here.
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
By far, by far!
Thank you!
-Whoa!
-That was, by far, the winner!
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet," and enjoy.